يعني انا النهارده في فقره فنيه في مدينه
زي زي اسكندريه فالموضوع كله مبهج جدا
الحقيقه الاول انا برحب بيك يا استاذ محمد
معانا صباح الخير صباح الفل صباح الخير
صباح النور عايزه اعرف الفكره جت منين كده
في البدايه والله حضراتكم ان احنا كنت انا
بغني في مسرحيه وكادي كانت بتمثل
فلقيت كادي جت في مره كده في البلوفر
بتقول لي وانت بتغني قلت له وانا كمان
بغني قلتلها بغني ليه قالت لي بغني لفيروز
فتتها سمعيني حاجه فغنيت لي مع ناريه فجري
الطريقه عن مامتها الاستاذ ساره الشيشتاوي
فقالت لي ايه رايك نعمله عوده انور وجدي
وفيروز فكره كويسه فاشتغلنا عليها وعملنا
اول حاجه معنا ريال وزعناه بتوزيع الجديد
والحمد لله يعني
الموضوع يعني نجح هنا الحمد لله والناس
حبيته مننا فبعد كده عملنا كروان الفن
وبعد كده شوفي عزيزي
طيب وانت يا كادي بقى بتحبي يعني تمثلي
ايه تاني غير فيروز فيروز
انا
ما بمثلش ما ببسلش ام كلثوم انا بحبها
طب وبتحبك
احنا عرضت مسرحيه كادي كانت مسرحيه شارلي
تمام انا نفسي بقى اعملها بقى حقيقي يعني
بقى مش في مش في موضوع مسرح بقى وكده لا
اعرضها الفيلم بقى
طب احنا ممكن بقى نشوف العرض بتاعكم كل
اسكندريه شافته
طيب يلا
معك يا بسكوته معي معك ايه
تيجي نروح عند البقال يلا بينا يلا بينا
[موسيقى]
نروح في الحال
يلا نجيب لحمه
[موسيقى]
وحمله خيار
خمس الوان
ونشتري بلف
ونشتري باند وكمان
[موسيقى]
وجنه كمان وكان
الله الله على العرض هيك يعني في طاقه
ايجابيه
ورجعونا سنين طويله لورا ونحن بنشكركم
جزيل الشكر ندى حجازي والعازف محمد كنيش
والفنانه الملقبه بفيروز الاسكندريه كادي
ثابت